hey guys welcome back to the just
playthings channel and welcome to the
journey again um
today we are going to be
talking about uh watching a video from
ben shapiro um
yeah have you seen ben shapiro before i
have seen him and i know to come
prepared
to talk to him because if you don't he
will he'll get you he'll destroy your
life yes he will destroy it completely
every time you've been here you've had
your mind blown so far
yeah i have so
so i'm gonna i'm gonna give you some
context so this was back when black
lives matter was in full swing oh
like everything was heated not not
george floyd it was like like after no
it was before that it was um let's see
2017. okay so i don't remember when like
which
like which
um person or which movement it was i
just remember like when this came out
this was in the heat of everything all
right all right before we get started
with this video make sure you like
comment and subscribe for my sanity and
sign up for memberships as well
yeah guys
sign up for memberships because um she
she she needs to be compensated for for
the for
the brain
it's just gonna go everywhere make it
make it full screen all right
here we go
according to pew research
the net worth of white families in 2013
was 141 000 for black families it was
eleven thousand even less than the
nineteen thousand it was in two thousand
seven
according to economist edward wolf of
the university of new york excluding
vehicles and other durables the median
black family worth is just seventeen
hundred dollars
while forty percent of black families
have zero or negative wealth
white family worth
in terms of uh financial worth is 69
times more than that of black families
given this disparity
how can you argue that racism is not a
driving factor in income inequality
because it has nothing to do with race
and everything to do with culture and
when you have a culture that doesn't
and when
and when
you know what explain to me you explain
to me why black kids aren't graduating
high school explain that one to me
explain to me why black kids are
shooting each other in rates
significantly higher than whites are
shooting each other explain why 13 of
the population is responsible for 50
percent of the murder explain to me why
they why the number of blacks black kids
in prison not for innocent reasons not
for walking down the street and getting
pulled into a prison is so high explain
if it has nothing to do with culture
explain to me why the single motherhood
rate in the black community jumped from
20 to 70 percent in the same course of
time that the civil rights movement has
made such tremendous strides is america
more racist now than it was in 1960 and
if it is please explain to me how that
happened
so what do i think those riots are i
think the depravity i think they're
thugs and i think if you really want to
make a difference thurgood marshall who
grew up just two blocks from there did
such a thing who was a contemporary of
martin luther king
the reaction that the two people the
black people
have
had
is exactly the reaction when someone
says it's not about race it's about
culture and no the videos that we just
watch it's like
because it sounds insensitive if you
don't know what he's talking about
exactly
yeah
and
oh goodness my lord and so
like that's that's literally the
reaction of everybody because they're
just like what do you mean it's not
about race like the he just said like
white people are making more black
people making less is obviously about
race and it's like when you don't know
just the information you automatically
jump to what's been given to you
and
i'm so hesitant to say stuff like that
because i'm like
but i've learned what it what i've
learned and it just
and you know what's crazy too is
disparity doesn't always mean
discrimination and this is something i
had to like
i always have to reiterate like indian
americans outburn white americans does
that mean yeah does that mean people
discriminate against white people
because people from india move to the us
and make more money wow
no india people from india just become
engineers software engineers you work
really hard
wow but that's the culture
and it's the same thing like like
white people or germans have more
engineers
does that mean engineering discriminates
against people that aren't german
no it's like that culture they push
engineering the nba
it's i don't know what percentage is
black but yeah i'm sure it's higher than
the population yeah does that mean the
nba discriminates against white people
no black people are just better yeah
and like different cultures push
different things
yeah yeah i can understand that like the
[Music]
i would say the asian culture it pushes
um
being more so in the medical field
academics
and academics as well
they they said that from an asian
asians
would outperform
other cultures even if they had a lower
iq
and i want to say it was like 12 iq
points which is a lot
lower someone would need to outperform
an or higher someone would need to
outperform an asian person wow because
that cult i mean you you've met asian
parents like they're always on their
kids about turning everything on time
where my mom was like
b's c's
as long as you're not getting d's your
free get degrees
yeah
she's like being an entrepreneur we
don't really care that much about school
but it's like it's different cultures
yeah
wow
okay here we go
now i'd like to skip over to dr seacrest
i i look at the baltimore uprisings as
more than just riots right i hate the
idea when you say thugs and riots right
white people riot as well when y'all win
super bowls two years in a row y'all get
off the hook don't make it seem like
it's just
true
so my 32nd answer is
i
i personally don't think that that is a
valid connection
because i don't know about
baltimore and the super bowls when they
win and what they do i don't know if it
has the same effect on the community as
um
it does like actual like riot because
i'm pretty sure
when the rams won the super bowl this
year people weren't going to shops and
destroying it and
doing all this negative stuff to the
community i'm pretty sure they were
celebrating yeah and so you can't you
can't connect
a sports event that has nothing to do
with it
anybody being separate people come
together for sports
and why does it matter like even even
let's say let's say white people riot
too that's not what they're asking yeah
like it's like that's like
you know you're talking about one
problem and then she's like well what
about that problem they're like we're
talking about this this problem yeah so
i'm pretty sure
i know personally if
if it was uh flipped and
say
everybody else was rioting but black
people i would still think the same
thing i'd be i would still have the same
thought that i'd think about rioting as
i would when anybody else does it like
when it happened during um
this last
election and all that rioting happened
in la personally it was scary i'm like
how how is destroying
businesses going to bring anything to
anyone and they're mostly black owned
businesses yeah and people and um there
were black owned people coming up like
how is this helping the community like
we're black owned and you're destroying
our business for what for what benefit
and we're trying to do something and
we're trying to
bring wealth back in the black community
but you're destroying it because why and
it's their livelihood like you you see
me you see how much i work on this right
if somebody looted my apartment i would
be crushed yeah like i can't even
imagine start you know what i'm saying
yeah like and i come from well
like my parents could probably
no don't get any ideas
don't get any ideas but my but my
parents could probably replace some of
this like they probably
but i'm saying like like imagine if you
came from nothing
that would take you a decade yeah
just as long as it takes it would take
you double and it's just like
like they probably just quit the
business like mm-hmm because they just
spent the last year's bit ten years
building it for some selfish idiots to
come right at their store in the name of
equality are you kidding me yeah i
i don't understand right watching the
watching the la riots it's crazy to say
l.a writes because i know there was one
years ago but watching it on tv watching
these kids
just
go in these stores and i've i was
looking at a shoe store that i've seen
in person and i knew the street that
they were on and i was like man i drove
i've drove down that street before i've
been on that street and just watching
them
ramsack these buildings and just go in
and take stuff and it's just like there
is how is this beneficial to anybody how
is this beneficial to any type of change
to anything they're just going in there
it's beneficial for them because they
get free stuff and they can resell it
and make money but it's not beneficial
for the community not for the business
owner at all
it it just doesn't
no and what type of people loot stores
it's not the people that are gonna do
something good with the money at all
it's just people who want to come up
that's all it is
like i mean
you you
believed in that like black lives matter
for a point in time right i did you you
would never loot a store because that's
not who you are
and it's just like the people that do
that are so selfish i don't know a
single person that would do that i
wouldn't associate yeah
yeah and it sucked to see
la there's there's a lot of things going
on in la but it sucks to see
buildings boarded up that were once like
filled with
stores and shops but now it's all
boarded up because people decided to
loot and go crazy for no apparent reason
and it just made it just made la look
ugly and it hurts everyone around them
too because then the stores can't hire
people
and it's it it's catastrophic to these
communities
[Music]
it's
it's
yeah
it's tough
is i feel the frustration
of what's happening in the community and
i think it's a symptom the the uprisings
are a symptom
of
a pressure that's been unaddressed for
too long
i'm offended by the language of uprising
applied to people who are breaking into
other black people's stores and looting
them uh this is not this is a lack of
values and people who people who are
destroying private property destroying
cop cars in an uprising against what
exactly against the black police chief
against a mostly minority police force
against the black mayor against the
black president against the black
attorney general against the entirely
against a city council that is nine of
15 are black and all 15 are elected
democrats
what is the uprising against what is it
seeking to achieve i still don't see
what exactly the the riots are seeking
to achieve bottom line is
this is all
it all could be boiled down to just act
like a mensch
act like a human being honestly it's not
a useful it's not useful to riot it's
not useful to break things it's not
useful to throw rocks at people and the
idea that we're supposed to sort of
correlate your level of allergies i'm
going to stick to the 30 seconds yeah
last one is the last sentence the idea
that we're supposed to correlate your
level of outrage with a certain level of
justification in other words the more
outraged you are and more angry you are
the more justified you must be is
absolute nonsense
[Applause]
because you wouldn't what he just said
right there the more angry you are the
more
crazy you are you're justifiable you
wouldn't say that in
any type of situation but if it comes to
anything you like okay since you were
that angry and that upset it's
justifiable
it just
it just does
you wouldn't and it's like why why would
you do it for writing and looting like
oh you were um you were angry and upset
that's justifiable you you tore down
this building lit it on fire that's
justifiable it's like they're treating
black people like children
like they're saying oh you're mad about
that you're having a temper tantrum it's
okay
like you know i mean like yeah and to me
that's offensive yeah it's
these are grown-ass adults yeah just
oh
these are grown-ass adults that you're
saying this is okay what are you talking
about and it's like the kids
the kids only follow what the
like the adults are doing and yes there
were some adults that were
not engaging in it but there was a lot
of adults that were like oh i want to be
on the come up too during um
during the last riot and then and then
these teenage kids young kids are like
oh i want to go on the come up too and
they're out and about and it's like
and it's like it's you're taking away
the consequence because how many did
they really press charges against the
people that did that oh no there were so
many you could
if you did that
i would a big chunk of la will be in
prison right now and they would have to
build a new prison to fit more people in
it
i want to hear what he said
since the issue of disparity has come up
a number of times when does disparity
not indicate racism
level of effort statistical disparity
you know for example overwhelmingly men
commit crimes more than women but we
don't say that the justice department is
sexist so
is there
is there a line that you draw for
yourself or is there some some way that
you interpret statistical disparity and
you determine that that is not a racial
disparity it's something else
crickets well we can return to it that's
okay too ben do you want to yes
and these are these are black like they
work at black lives matter
oh okay and this this is like the the
hard thing about it is like i'm pretty
sure
these two
uh the black woman the black man
i'm pretty sure they're of a
value like high value and high stature
within the black community because
they're well educated they sat in there
and i'm not taking that away from them
but it's like he asked a simple question
if it's not about if it's not about
racism when it comes to statistical uh
disparity what is it there has to be
something else and for them not to be
able to answer it and it'd just be like
race race race race race race it's like
how are how how is a community how is a
people supposed to
supposed to grow
and
develop
better
if it's just like race race race race
race race race and
it's
it's
crazy
to
to
be going on this journey and hearing
these videos watching them and seeing
this and it's just like
why
why isn't someone like thomas like
someone that people that
some someone that people listen to and
i've had people tell me like oh you
should listen to
um tamasaw he's a uh
the support of white supremacy blah blah
blah but i'm like the stuff that he's
listening to i i hear it and i'm not
taking i'm not taking it like oh i'm
just gonna dismiss what it is that i
have in my brain i'm going to listen to
it
try to understand it and
see how can this
if someone here says how can this help
them as a black person and if i don't
see
any negative
benefits to it i'm just like this is
something that is beneficial but people
just take it dismiss it and it's like
something we've learned it's already
started on it's just like it was a
simple question if you can't answer it
you're educated well educated and if you
can't answer that there's something it's
something different
you know what's crazy sol says
the best thing about having a harvard
degree is not being impressed by people
with harvard degrees some of the dumbest
people i ever met are super well
educated
like i i don't think education
anymore correlates to intelligence i
think oh no no i think it did at one
point but i know too many dumb ass
people yes even in my program i'm like
these are going to be therapists
yes god help god help them
i'm in the psychology program
literally i'm like i'm just doing this
for fun
but i'm like y'all are using this
you plan on helping people i'm like i
they get worse grades than me right wow
and i you know me i barely care about
school i'm like i'm just sure like
maybe i'll do it
yeah
i'll do it because i don't really care i
primarily yeah of course but they're
like i'm like you you really want to be
there like how the hell are you yeah
like
that is so cool and they'll go around
telling everyone oh i have a masters i
have a master's i might they're
like there's no
is it
common sense is free
common sense is free well that's why
people like you yeah it's not it's not
because they don't know what your
education is but they just can tell you
of common sense yeah and i feel like
people associate
being well educated with common sense no
no no have you ever seen this show it
was like an old show back in the day it
was called streets street smarts or
street something
it was this show where um
they would bring on people
and they would go into the streets do
interviews
and it was kind of like
common sense was the questions they were
asking it was like oh do you have street
smarts and they would be well-educated
people come on and they wouldn't know
the simple stuff and it's like man
common sense is free people
it's it's called evidence of racism when
there is no evidence of racism it's
probably not racism when there is actual
evidence of racism it's probably racism
and the fact that everybody jumps from
there's inequality and therefore there
is inequity just because there's
inequality does not mean there was
inequity but there has to be racism you
can't be considerate in the racism
no no no no no no i'm just saying that i
don't know which animal or maybe
maybe we're talking about dogs or
something i'm talking about human beings
and i'm like human beings are most
likely gonna have racial prejudices i'm
just so sorry i i'm just so sorry i i
don't know i
i i i don't come i'm i don't come i come
i come from i come from planet earth
charles i just i want to ask you a
question so your default your default is
that when there is no evidence racism is
the deciding factor no no no i was not
saying that i'm just saying that uh that
you're going to have sexist you're going
to have racists you're going to have all
this stuff i mean i'm just saying that i
agree it exists but the problem that i'm
seeing and this is the problem with the
general conversation is that there's no
solution in simply saying there's racism
out there how does that solve anything i
mean when you talk about there's
institutional racism what does that mean
show me a law that is racist in intent
and we will agree show me a police
officer who commits a racist act like we
saw in south carolina right where a
police officer shot a black man running
away and it was obviously unjustified
and i will agree
but you know
the the idea that you can craft a
narrative based on no racism because it
just must be somewhere out there in the
ether that doesn't solve problems for
anybody and creates more problems for
people because now they grow up in a
milieu in an environment where they are
told that every obstacle they face is
from some shadowy nameless faceless
group who is out to get them simply
because of the color of their skin
they'll never succeed in that
environment
um
snaps snaps snap snaps that
that is
so true because if you if you keep
say um
say you uh you
broke something
and you got better but i'm like ah you
remember you had you had that broken
bone you you had that broken bone you're
not going to
you're not going to be as
uh mentally a hundred percent to be able
to do certain things that you want to do
because you're always thinking oh i have
that broken bone i can't do things 100
anymore i had that broken bone but if i
told you you had that broken bone but it
healed and then here's some things to
make it better and get better you're
going to be you're going to have the
mindset to be like okay
yes i had a broken bone
i can do things to get better and to be
in a better situation i don't know if
that was a good analogy that's a great
analogy but it's like if you keep
feeding someone
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad you
can't do this you can't do that because
of this this this they're going to be
like man i
want to go do that i could see myself
doing something like that i could see
myself being
in the top percentile but
bad bad bad bad bad it's not it's not
beneficial it's focusing on the problem
and not the solution yeah
because even even
me when i'm like trying to figure
something out when i feel myself getting
really frustrated it's because i i'm
always focusing on the problem and not
and this is something my dad always has
taught me like if you're in a fight with
someone
even like this isn't a race thing but
like yeah yeah just say the same concept
right yeah like but like if you're if
you're in a fight with someone right
like if you focus on all the things
they're doing wrong you're never going
to come to a solution yeah and so like
and even when i'm frustrated with the
equipment or whatever like if i keep
thinking oh this equipment is shitty
like you have to always focus on the
solution and that's like that's what all
he's doing in this is he's focusing like
this is a problem this is a problem but
like what what's your solution yeah and
he he um
uh ben shapiro shapiro yeah shapiro he
he presented him with the question and
he was like no i'm not saying that but
based on your response when he asked if
like when the moderator asked the
question you had nothing to say for it
if you have something to say for it
he said it must be racism yeah he's like
it must be it must be and it's just like
i
it's just so it's so frustrating i'm not
saying that it's not
there i'm not saying it disappeared and
there's no such thing as it yes it i
would say there are people who are
racist
i don't know
anybody
up front
but
it's like if you keep feeding that
narrative nothing nothing's going to get
better nothing's going to change if
someone told me that
oh
youtube is
is just a white sector everybody on
those races you shouldn't even go on
youtube because
you're gonna get called this that in the
third i would have never i probably
would have never done it would have
never thought about even starting a
channel would have never thought about
coming and use it every white person on
there is racist all they all it is if
you go on there it's just further for
your benefit blah blah blah i would have
i would have never what if what if they
did that with me because i'm sure at
some point that's what they'll do with
me yeah right like with um the channel
because like i say things people don't
like yeah
but if they if people got to you first
then that's what you would have thought
you probably never like you got to you
got to quit your day job
i never would have came on the pod i
never i wouldn't be sitting here because
i've been like no i'm not about to put
myself
in a situation since someone told me
that
it's nothing but racist people and
they're nothing but people that go
against
who i am yeah
yeah and it wasn't like like i didn't
you just showed up on time and you did a
good job and i was like oh she'd be a
good hire
i just
did me
literally
and is this lady that's on the right
side well the right side of the screen
is she
white latina okay i thought so yeah
you know the weirdest thing is that
actually in the black hole as i
experienced it really um there is no
discussion of racism
a racism energy is a discussion that you
actually come out and you face
in in the public because it's a real
thing that you have to actually expect i
mean if you you're silly and you're
foolish if you don't if you don't really
think that that what that something that
i've noticed
is
yes it may be out there but you
i don't know if this is naive thinking
but i heard so many black people talk
about
i've heard just people in general talk
about how
um
just uh
they expect it they're like already
anticipating it like if you're gonna if
you're looking for it you're gonna find
something just like in a relationship if
you're looking for a man to be
unfaithful or a woman to be a faithful
you're gonna find what you're looking
for don't be upset when it comes to you
and it's like
and so i'm like i when people talk about
um like racism that they face and when
i'm not saying i'm not disregarding
their stories disregarding their
experiences but i'm like they asked me
like how is it out here like i hear
about it i'm like i i personally
haven't experienced it and it may people
may experience it i'm not saying that
it's not but i'm like i don't when i
walk out my door i'm not expecting
this white person to walk past me and
call me a racial slur i'm not expecting
that to be a thing cause i'm like i
don't want that i don't want that to be
the thing that i'm expecting like i walk
out into the world and it's just like
this is going to happen i know some
people don't expect that but it's like
it's just
mindset i have a story story so my ex
boyfriend had a good a decent like chunk
of change right you know he went into a
bank once
and they were kind of like questioning
that it was um
like how he had so much money like
something that like seemed to him racist
right but to me i'm like you're dressed
like a bum
yeah like if you walked in a suit they
probably with your hair groomed and all
this stuff like i and it could have been
it's just funny though because we both
saw the same situation
in a completely different way because
his default was more oh they must be
racist and my default is
i mean i would probably question you too
your pants are on the ground mm-hmm like
yeah like if you if you came in in a
suit with your hair group like you
probably would have a completely
different experience
but it's funny because i don't even want
to say funny but it's just interesting
that me and him
have like we'll look at the same
situation and maybe it's because i'm
white i don't know
but
like
i'm just like because my cousin jimmy um
he he passed away but he had a lot of
the same um experiences that like i hear
white black people talk about with
police
like with they but it was because he was
addicted to cocaine or crack so i'm like
yeah
of course of course you don't like
police because they're always arresting
you yeah
of course and when you were talking
about uh your ex-boyfriend's bank
incident it made me think about
um
the
um
not is it producer the
the one who the
producer who created and i think i'm
saying the wrong word um
black panther like the
main guy for and i
can't remember his name right now he
walked into the bank and they wouldn't
allow him to withdraw money from his
uh his account
and
when certain situations like that come
up i'm like well he
i don't know what he looked like i don't
know the situation but it's like it's
hard not to be like that's racism that's
racism and it's it's
something that i i struggle with to be
like okay that's racism that's not
racism that's racism that's not racism
it's just like
when do when do where do we define it
where do we notify it and it's like you
can't you can't say everything
is racism because then you're just
staying in that mindset that no matter
what you do no matter how
how far along you get in life is always
it could be ageism people don't think
young people have that much money
exactly and if someone if someone i bet
you and
i literally as i talk i hear like
counter like arguments like well
why didn't this why didn't that and i'm
just like it's like literally my brain's
like well this well that well this that
and i'm just like yeah no but it's the
point is you don't know you'll never
know why someone is doing something yeah
they could just be an [ __ ] and they
and like literally i don't know where he
was they probably never knew who he was
they probably didn't ever see black
panther they probably did see black
panther but didn't care to
um research who the creator was and
this sound the third so they probably
just
saw him and was like you want how much
out of your account no
you i don't know who you are or why you
think you can withdraw that much and so
i i don't know it just could have just
been a karen yeah literally that too
good old karen but i mean it also could
have been racism yeah
you just never know yeah
never know
that's gonna be there and encountered in
the real world i'm sorry this is just a
fact of life but if i'm at home and
having dinner uh with my father or
whatever we don't go oh my god this
society is so racist as i'm eating my
steak and you know what i mean
oh goodness gracious oh i could go for a
stick right now stick sounds good where
is my black skin is causing you anyway
no
we don't smash your pass oh defile pass
definitely pass on both yeah he's very i
would love to have a conversation i'll
go i'll go to dinner and have a
conversation with him but nothing after
that talk like that actually we don't
talk like that we talk about my god um
what's her name oh my god she's got to
take some pills because she's off the
register i mean i mean it's just like
this these are the conversations
i'm like i don't know what conversations
you're having with your family like
off the register you got to take some
pills like no
and like he was saying that they don't
talk about racism in their home like oh
this world's a racist
black families have those conversations
but it may not be the way he's talking
about
and
yeah that's all that's all i'm gonna say
about it
at home
we don't have these kinds of
conversations that we're having right
now at least my childhood we didn't have
them and i what
like they're saying the conversation
that they have right now maybe they
should maybe they should have
conversations like this too you'd
probably be better prepared yeah
like
i mean you clearly don't yeah
maybe they like there should be
conversations like ask ask a child like
okay
this is the stats so here there's a
stats there what do you think if it's
not racism what is the disparity here
and see what they come up with see what
is in their brain to help them
understand things maybe conversations
like this should be had in the black
home
yeah i don't
i don't know what household he grew up i
don't i don't know
he's like saying some of these
conversations yeah like oh aunt
so-and-so's off the register she's gotta
take her who has conversations like that
like
the people i knew growing up in the
black neighborhood i didn't hear anybody
really talking about race when we were
at the dinner table i mean he just
didn't realize okay cap you're telling
me george floyd
yeah nobody everybody just say someone
how's your day oh my day was swell honey
like oh i caught some fish out back or
whatnot like
people did not talk about that yeah come
on
come on yeah like i
i had so many people text me they're so
mad at me for not posting the black
square what's the black screen you
remember the black square oh oh i didn't
even do that i'm like what the i'm like
okay one i was literally thinking like
the square is going to change society
yeah i'm like
this is gonna help what's going on and
too at that time i still knew what i
knew about black lives matter so i'm
like why would i post the square yeah
and so many people did it and
i was like why i i didn't do it i'm like
why are we posting a black square and oh
and people were like oh if you don't
post a black square you're not an ally
you're not for the community and i'm
like how does that show that someone's
an ally someone that's not an ally could
just be posting in black square for
clout does it say oh i'm for the black
community but not be for anything
beneficial it's like what are they doing
how is it going to change anything i
will never publicly
like
like because to me if you're posting
that that implies you are doing
something to help what percentage of
them actually donated yeah money i i
donated money to george floyd's family
and i'm like like so that that's more
helpful than your freaking black yeah
freaking square black square
is not a petition it doesn't change
anything it's not a law it's just like
when i saw that i was like i'm not i'm
not posting a black square
and it's just
pop-up unless he was in the issuers on
television but mostly it was about
family and and regular life but i
disagree i have to tell you even in my
culture there is an underlying racism
and i know that the panel today and
especially what's going on america we're
talking about white on black but you
cannot i cannot wake up in the morning
and not think about you know
intercultural racism okay i'm not
mexican enough why because i'm
articulate and because i have straight
hair and i can wear high heels i don't
have a tattoo on my neck yes there is a
huge problem with racism no matter if
you're light-skinned or dark-skinned
absolutely there is interco
that's that's another thing that's also
what i was i was going to say
when i do say oh i don't experience
racism it's automatically your light
skin so you can't like or that's why you
don't experience this it's like
but i thought all black people like
experience it it doesn't it doesn't
matter if i'm light-skinned or
dark-skinned i'm black and
people are gonna go against me and what
she was saying is
also true like intercultural racism
there are
uh doug on the live he asked me he's
like what's your favorite thing about
being black and i told him i said
he said what's your favorite thing and
your least favorite thing about being
black i said my answer for my answer is
the same for my lead my favorite and my
least favorite i said it's the people i
said i love the people but we are our
own worst critic i said we can support
each other
100 one moment and then the next moment
just be the worst and just dis discount
a black person immediately and i'm like
why is that and i've said this before
i'm like how do we expect people to
support us from the outside if we're not
even supporting our own people from the
inside and how do we expect change if
all we're doing on the inside is just
chaos and
we try to go outside of it and it's just
like oh if someone does step out to try
to bring information in and it's like oh
no you're not you're not for us because
you're talking like this person over
here and it's just like
why
culture racism it's absolutely
underlying and why you may not talk
about it your grandmother will have the
favorite grandkid if she's the lightest
one with the good hair that becomes the
favorite grandkid in our culture and
that's you know unfortunately even
within our own cultures we tend to look
upon you know the color of each other's
skin and how much education we have and
if my uncle has done time in jail which
you know he has then he becomes more
mexican than i am what is up with that i
mean it's sad but it's true it's
absolutely true it's like i can't eat
spicy picante sauce so i'm not mexican
enough you know it's true you know in
every culture whether it's asian you
know black mexican there is while you
may not have grown up talking about it
over your you know
tea and toast i mean in my family if
you're not a doctor or lawyer you're not
jewish you're not jewish enough
and i've heard i've had a friend
she was talking to this black guy
and he hadn't seen a certain movie she
was like uh he's not black enough like
how do you expect me to be
with somebody that doesn't have like the
black experience and i think he was he
was mixed he was a mix he was half black
and something else and she's like yeah
he's not black enough like i want my
husband to be able to
talk to my men about the but my kids
about the black experience but he's not
black enough just because he hasn't seen
a movie i
we were talking about the black card the
other day and i
i
just i love it and dislike it at the
same time because it's like if i have it
if you not have if you haven't seen
certain movies oh you're not black
enough if you don't talk a certain way
oh you're not black enough if you don't
look a survey oh you're not black and i
was like how can i
be comfortable in myself
and walk out the door be like okay i'm
black i can walk it but
if i have my own people saying you're
not black enough because i don't like
where is the stipulation that i
i cannot
stand it it doesn't because when you
think about it like
what is the nigerian nigerian-american
not black
yeah yeah parents is going to be
completely exactly a black canadian
exactly or a black guy in the south
like what what is the black experience
yeah i just don't get it and i've i've
said this i think i've talked i've
talked to somebody about this or i've
just talked to myself about it and it's
just like you never know somebody's
upbringing you you may have had someone
that was brought up a certain way to
where the quote-unquote black movies
that we had to watch growing up
you they didn't watch it as a kid or
their parents didn't want that
infiltrated into their mindset so they
didn't watch him what if he's just a
hard worker and he doesn't watch movies
that too and it's like you can't
discount somebody because they didn't
watch this or they don't listen to this
or they don't act this way for not being
who they are born to be
and it's it's frustrating so what she
said oh cute and single i mean
i don't remember
there's been so many i don't remember
not really i'd be lonely
somebody come come get pearl somebody
wipe her up
it's true that part is true
oh
this entire time i've been trying to
think about your initial question about
disparities are they automatically tied
to race and at first i think all of us
were stumped because we're trying to
think of the instances i
i do agree that they are separate that
they don't necessarily correlate within
itself there are disparities in the
naacp we are the experts inside of the
nation of bringing in the racial
lens for all of the work no they're not
necessarily going hand in hand or
they're not necessarily tied to each
other
so that was that's how i would answer it
no
they don't have to go together my job as
a civil rights attorney is to be able to
make you see race at every given
opportunity but no it's not present in
each and every single disparity did you
hear her it's it's to make you see race
in every single opportunity oh no i
missed it i was stuck on her being a
civil rights attorney i was like and you
couldn't answer a simple question
yeah
don't necessarily correlate within
itself there are disparities naacp we
are the experts inside of the nation of
bringing in the racial
lens for all of the work no they're not
necessarily going hand in hand or
they're not necessarily tied to each
other um so that was that's how i would
answer it no
they don't have to go together my job as
a civil rights attorney is to be able to
make you see race at every given
opportunity but no it's not present in
each and every single disparity
why though
why
like from the horse's mouth
to me help you see
see what if what
is not even in there why see it it's
like i mean if it's there it's there but
like she literally said it is my job to
make you see it at every single given
opportunity like this is from from the
horse's mouth
like and it's one thing if if it's if
racism is there there's evidence of it
like that is a completely different
thing but like it is my job to make you
see race
at every single given opportunity every
single
given opportunity that goes back to my
analogy earlier if
and this is so will calls them race
hustlers because they know there's money
in racism
what would she do what would her job be
this is her job she would be out of the
job if they said oh no actually it's not
really that big of a thing yeah like th
these are the stats you can do anything
you don't need the government
you don't need us to fight for you you
can do it
about where would her job go poof gone
oh
yeah i'm i'm flabbergasted i literally
have no words i'm lost firms
to your second what are the standards
what are the standards the difference i
mean you said that you want people to
see race in every single issue
where it's present okay so for instance
that's not what you said first
yeah as to where it's present absolutely
what's my um
for the take something as simple as a um
if we're talking about a disparity say
men and women um
my job would be to show what does that
look like when you have women from um a
different
group communities of color what does it
look like when we're talking about a
woman who's working or stuck in a
minimum wage job not being not as a
starter but for her career right now i
guess the question is like so we bring
in the racial dynamic of how that
affects i understand that the question
that i'm asking is when do you decide
something racist has a but how is
a man
and a woman
what does it have to do with race and
they bring in they bring it in from a
racial dynamic if a woman is if a person
is in a minimum wage job as their career
there's something
that is there that can't that they
cannot excel to the next level
it has nothing
to do
from my knowledge it has nothing to do
with race if i'm if i'm if i wasn't at
this point in my life where i'm at with
a college degree and athletics
i would be here and if i don't do
anything to
make myself marketable to be able to
excel i'm not going to if someone's 40
and still making minimum wage i think
it's a them problem yeah it's not it's
not a
it's not i don't think it's a race
problem it's literally and if someone
says oh
in the end
if someone's like i wasn't able to
progress because
i'm black
and like someone laid out someone had
like a scroll full of opportunities like
nah you could have done all this stuff
there's people black people own
businesses too yeah and it's like how
can
how can we how can she say that like i
show the the racial parts of it and it's
just like when you see people that
are
that may have started off at a minimum
wage job but they progress like
why is it just
based on race people did that when they
were i mean booker t washington
he went around giving speeches and he
was born a slave yeah so if they did it
then
why on earth can people not do it today
and i it was a question that i won the
last and asked in the last video i
wonder why like
we talk about butcher t but booker t
washington as a slave and getting out
and educated we won't talk about like
you said his autobiography earlier where
he talked about his relationship
with um
his
slave master right and
um
it's just
it's it's
it's crazy to you know this is crazy
there are accounts of okay
they freed the slaves right but there
are some slaves that were like freed
early and they they had to pay a certain
amount back like as like they were free
they would travel across states to pay
their slave owners back even when they
didn't have to because they felt end so
indebted to them
and like those stories you don't hear
about there's stories where
there was um a family like after slavery
the the slaves were all gone the slaves
all raised the drunken sun that was like
the town drunk
he was just a [ __ ] up and the slaves
were so felt so indebted to that family
that they raised the sun
and it's like the and that's why when i
say okay
and i hate saying this because it sounds
so bad but when you say like like
slavery it wasn't like every master was
like a terrible owner some were some
were awful got off their horror stories
but there's also stories like that
and it's like my question is
like why were people able to do it then
after slavery
and like why wouldn't you be able to do
it today yeah
it's
oh
i'm not going to have a brain after this
it's just going to be mush
good thing you're going on vacation yep
i'm just going to be laying on the
beaches like
just mush
racist yes when when do you have you
when can you decide that an act of
racism has occurred because if you have
just a statistical disparity has it has
an act of racism automatically occurred
that was david's basic question i think
right there's a there's obviously a
there might be a um
there will be a disparate impact on
uh different groups of people that
doesn't necessarily mean i think what
you're saying it doesn't necessarily
mean something racist is going on even
though there's a racial impact so the
question was about where do you draw the
line between something that might have a
racial impact but is not inherently
racist
yeah
let me move on
wow wow wow wow
my goodness um
how's your day going
you know
it's oh
it's going good it's going good
i'm not saying that these by any far
these videos are bad it's just like
they're mind-blowing it is and it
combats with
like what i've been taught and like
when i hear this stuff
i i want to be able to hear it like
clearly and not have just like the
combatants with it and just thinking
about what i've learned
what i've been taught in the black
community and then like the people i
know
like
how
what they would say to me and like how
they would like come at me and i'm just
like this is so it's it's a lot but i
i'm enjoying it yeah at the same time
and it's just like eye opening
and honestly this is something that
i've just wanted to like hear i wanted
to hear like a different narrative for
so long i'm like i can't it can't be
like this it can't be this way and i've
had that thought and i i don't voice it
to people because people are gonna be
like no this is how it's always been and
i
and i know that because i'll have
certain conversations with people just
to see like where do they stand how
how do they like position themselves and
if they answered a certain way i know
that i cannot talk to them about xyz and
i don't and it's just like
man
changes your view on the world it does
it does i already had a thought
but
stuff like this it like
confirms it's like ah tick tick tick
and
oh
yeah
wow okay
well i hope you enjoyed this video
make sure you like comment and subscribe
to the channel and also sign up for
memberships for more exclusive content
and she's going on vacation
yeah you can get a behind-the-scenes
look at her vacation yeah also follow my
channel if you want to see more vlogs
and learn more about myself it is it's
your girl jess on youtube the link's in
the description yes it is have a great
day bye
[Music]